Brendan Shaw gave a breakdown of Dustin
versus Justin and
I'm telling you I'm telling you what
Brendan said because I'm stealing it
that's not what I'm going to say I loved
what he said it was real simple he
talked about essential and I'm going to
change his words here but what Brennan
was talking about is that Poirier is
very technical and
gaichi is a brawler he suspects there's
going to be more grappling in this than
you suspect or grappling than we saw in
the first match and that it's gonna be
initiated that's a quote from Brennan
guys don't try to take him down it's not
a matter that he's using wrestling
defensively guys read the resume they
have a respect for him and then they
don't try to take him down I like
Brendan's analysis
and that is very much a tool that
Poirier has and this is such a classic
match guys of technician versus brawler